all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
so
um I wanted to talk about how
I think a lot of times there are like
bailout messages
and how my life would be so much easier
if I was more committed to just sounding
good rather than saying things that are
true
so what what do I mean by this so a lot
of times I get a lot of slack on here
and I saw a comment the other day was
like Pearl like what's your moving
forward message
um and what's your solution like they
think Pearl's the one with all the
solutions because I can identify
problems Pearl needs to prescribe
Solutions so and I have a couple ideas
but
um I wanted to show you guys what
I've just noticed
so let's talk about the perceived value
of women we have all this messaging in
society that tells women that we are
special and important
and anytime you go
against the mainstream narrative and you
say you know what I actually don't think
women are that special or that important
the men and women will just come after
you and it doesn't really matter if you
have data and facts to back it up like
for example if I say you know
men aren't really that important or
special
I I think most men would agree with
special but in terms of important to
running a society that would really be a
lie because again half of men have
infrastructure jobs so half of men have
jobs that make keep the lights on the
plumbing on
uh or women's only seven percent like I
think one of the number one employers of
men in the US is like truckers you know
we need Truckers so this is the
perceived value
um but you could even say those things
and not get that much pushback but the
interesting thing is if I say women
aren't that special or important
I then am demonized
and criticized for life now what makes a
woman special and important and I was
thinking about this I have a marker just
because I'm a visual person
um
so maybe I want you know uh purity
youth children right just just Bare
Bones
you know femininity
and if I say you know what today let's
just take a look around right
I'm not blind I don't think most women
are that feminine I don't think most
women are that pure
you know and I was thinking about this
body count thing I was thinking about
how under five men is the new standard
for virginity
you know I heard a guy on a podcast he
was a virgin and he was a Christian guy
waiting for marriage and he said he'd
accept like five and I was thinking
like if you had five guys in a room
together you would be like wow that's
that's a good amount of people it's a
little party in here but it's
interesting because
like women we've almost found ways to
like
navigate this because women want men to
think their perceived value is here all
right this is what they they want
and the problem is we have all this
messaging and media that tells us our
perceived value is here it says you're
important you're special you know and
and they they feed this to us constantly
because the companies are trying to sell
to us the politicians are trying to make
us vote for that like there's there's no
one really the men are trying to get us
to sleep with them there's no one being
honest with women
and the unfortunate part about being the
one that's like all right I'm gonna be
honest
is you just get hate for life it is like
it would be so much easier to just yeah
but
so this is the perceived value of the
women
um and you know maybe this would be the
value of the women if we were virgins
and offered men like seven children
but the actual value
is more like here you know what no
that's a little too high I'm gonna make
it lower
perceived actual and we let women live
in this La La Land right they let us
live in this delusion for example all
these brides are wearing white on their
wedding day when none of them were
virgins so in a way it's kind of like
playing pretend like you're pretending
to be a wife you know it's all just like
this show like I was thinking about how
crazy it is that we have wives coming in
that have slept with more than five
dudes and have children you have proof
of another man's child and you're coming
in wearing white and maybe you guys
don't think it's that deep right but I
it just is another example about how the
world shields us from consequences
and I think that the only real solution
going forward is for women to have
consequences
um and anyway so the issue
is the men don't want to admit this
because a lot of men would realize
they've been bamboozled right
the women don't want to admit this
because then
um the men would then say Oh like
then they might actually get what they
deserve which you know most single
mothers don't really deserve marriage
um
non-virgins don't deserve marriage
nobody really deserves anything
um but the the mindset should be you're
lucky if you get it but the problem is
we have media and messaging that's
constantly telling us we're special
constantly telling us we should be
bailed out of our poor decisions and
nobody tells us the truth and the truth
of the matter is it's far more kind to
be honest with women than to constantly
tell us we're more important and more
special than we are and at some point
women we really got to get pissed off
because we got to be sick of getting
pandered to
and you know it would be so much easier
for me to say hey
um you know this is the solution going
forward
and get married get married get married
start a family get married young but in
all honesty that really benefits the
women and doesn't benefit the met and
until women start getting our
Percy or per our actual value to our
perceived value until we start filling
this Gap I really don't see an incentive
for men to get married
um and you know maybe this is a bit
hypocritical because I want to get
married but
I think
you know as a society the best solution
would be for women to actually face
consequences stop marrying the single
mothers you know stop letting women get
away with demasculating men
um and be honest with women about our
perceived value Margot Robbie is mid I'm
so tired of these coping single mothers
trying to act like they're hotties in
your in their 30s they were probably mid
in their 20s they're probably slightly
less mid now
most people are mid I was I was mid at
20. I'll be less mid at 30. this is life
but we've we've spent a lifetime of
you know where you can't you can't say
things that are true without being
criticized so for example you know
I I you know I I set off
conservative Twitter conservative
Twitter which is supposed to be based on
facts and not Feelings by saying 25 year
old women are are hotter than 35 year
old women I also set off conservative
Twitter by saying hey women's jobs
aren't as important as we think
and instead of sitting back the women
and thinking huh is that true
and if you look at the numbers sorry
ladies none of our shits as important as
the men's like
uh we dominate in some Fields but
usually those fields suck you know what
I I was looking at this I was thinking
about how Dentistry
how I got my wisdom teeth removed and I
have all these jaw issues and I was
literally thinking about
whenever women come into an industry
Elliott but my point isn't
you know to have a battle of the sexes
but my my real point is it's funny how
the conservatives come in and ask for a
solution for women well what are the
women supposed to do well
improve
or die alone
and unfortunately
um I don't say this with a happy heart
most of the women
I really see a large
growing segment of the population
dying alone because really in society
this is what we have and I noticed this
I want roller I went to a roller rink
this weekend and I noticed how it was
really all single people like you'll
notice this under 40 guys it's a
different game it's mostly single people
or married women that act like single
single women most of them with open
Instagrams most of them get attention
from other men really in society we have
the
the Kings
and the peasants
and really the Kings
keep all the
on rotations and situationships
and The Peasants are lonely men
and the success Hustler guys will come
in and say peasants become a king just
become a king and the peasants are like
well not everyone can become a king
and then the the trade cons will say
well it's the king's fault for screwing
the horse
and the kings are like well
it wasn't like she was a virgin right
it's like they're like well she wanted
to be a and
and yeah so
you know sorry guys sometimes I'm a
little chaotic but
my point is this my point is any time
you tell women they're not that
important or not that special you're
demonized and anytime you tell women
they are that important they are special
and they're going to be young and
Youthful and hot forever
then
you make money so I I suggest going that
route so you don't have to be the most
hated person on the internet by the left
and the right I say just Pander for a
lifetime just Pander you'll you'll make
the most money anyways guys I gotta go
to the gym so
um thanks for watching my morning coffee
thoughts
any advice
for me getting up in the morning because
I'm trying to become a morning person
I'm going to do it I'm going to stay
morning I am a morning person now
anyways like the video I'll talk to you
guys later